the cbs this morning saturday the covet
19 pandemic has put a spotlight on
so-called wet markets where
animals are sold and sometimes
slaughtered scientists believe a wet
market in wuhan china could be where the
coronavirus first jumped from animals to
humans
now there's a growing effort around the
world to shut these markets down
and as jim axelrod shows us hundreds of
them are right here
in the u.s last month small groups of
animal rights protesters gathered at
some of the more than
70 live animal markets that operate
legally around new york city
these are not the same type of markets
like those in china that sell exotic
animals
generally when people are talking about
wet markets they're talking about
live animal markets where
either livestock or wildlife for exotic
animals can be sold
dr ben lotman an infectious disease
epidemiologist at the rollins school of
public health at emory university
says the live animal markets here pose
their own
significant health threat anywhere that
humans
come into contact with animals is a
potential
exposure there's a potential opportunity
for an infection to jump from animals to
humans you know live markets they might
pose a special risk because of the
diversity of animals that are sold
according to the cdc more than six out
of every
10 known infectious diseases in people
can be spread from animals
tetris adenom heads the world health
organization
wet markets are an important source of
affordable
food and livelihood for millions of
people all over the world but in many
places they have been
poorly regulated and poorly maintained
video obtained by cbs news from animal
rights activists
of live animal markets coast to coast
show unsanitary conditions
animals in cages stacked on top of each
other with feces
urine or blood able to flow between
cages
in terms of how sanitary these markets
are
did these markets pose any kind of
health
threat i wouldn't eat from one of those
markets
new york state legislator linda
rosenthal is alarmed at what she
says is the lack of oversight from state
and local governments
she has introduced a bill that would
shut down the markets
while the risk is evaluated it's really
a matter of
public health come see what we do
before you make past judgment we keep
all our animals separate
we sanitize multiple times a day it's
part of our routine before kovid
imramuden's family has run a live animal
market for 64 years
in queens new york and says they are
vital for customers wanting kosher or
halal meat for a lot of my clientele
it's a tradition
it's a way of preserving their way of
life since the covid crisis began new
york state has stopped inspecting live
animal markets
assemblywoman rosenthal has sponsored a
bill that would suspend the licenses of
existing live animal markets
and stop issuing any new ones for cbs
this morning saturday this is jim
axelrod
in montclair new jersey
there is much more news ahead